The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
All right, let's take a whirlwind tour through
religious media over the last six days with
you, it's very interesting what's happening in
religious right media right now, absent evidence
that is convincing in a court which was all thrown
out over the last two months, religious media
has been taking a prophecy approach to Donald
Trump being the real winner of the November 2020
presidential election. They've been taking the
approach that God or the Bible or prophecy or
sacred texts can explain what is happening with
Joe Biden. And it can be the source of hope that
Donald Trump is going to somehow reappear in the
Oval Office sometime very soon. And this is really
amazing. Now, as you know, I believe this is
delusion. I believe that this is a form of mental
illness. If it's not merely a grift to make money,
it may just be a scam. But I believe if the
things you're going to hear now are real beliefs,
I believe that that is mental illness. And I
want to be sort of really clear when people say,
you know, it's rude to call this mental illness.
I'm going to explain more about this. I don't
think there's anything rude whatsoever about what
I'm saying. Let's take a look at the first clip.
This is right wing pastor Hank Honeyman
who prophesied or prophecies prophecy.
I don't know. He predicted that Trump's reelection
would happen. He's now fighting back against
people who are saying you were wrong, Hank.
You said that Trump was going to be reelected.
Maybe you are a false prophet. And cognomen
says, well, God hates it when you say that.
He didn't say he hates discord. He hates he.
He hates you better being a troll, he hates
you. They are attacking your
Christian brothers and sisters.
Yeah, but they're false, they're wrong. Excuse
me, how do you know, because it doesn't come to
pass. How do you know that it hasn't come
to pass? First of all, the president was
reelected. Let's get that clear. Second of all,
he was given a second term based on reelection.
Well, he's not serving it
now because it was stolen.
By thieves, doesn't that make sense to
everyone, just perfectly clear now, again,
if he believes that, I believe that that is deep
mental illness and I know some of you are going
to write to me or say, David, that's alienating
to the religious folks in your audience. It's
offensive to all religious people. And I'm here to
tell you the answer is no. If you were nominally
Catholic, for example, and you go to church and
you believe there's some greater power at play,
but you're not so diluted that you think God
is controlling elections or that Joe Biden
has the mark of the beast or God is speaking
through people like Hank Cornerman. You and I
might disagree. I'd say, you know, I don't see
evidence for your understanding of the world,
but I wouldn't say that you're deluded or mentally
ill. Nominally Jewish beliefs about a greater
force could be a God, could be something else,
some kind of energy. That's not this. This is
something else. Let's not conflate when I say
this is deep delusion, this with the nominally
religious beliefs that tens of millions of
Americans hold. There is a difference here. Even
if I don't subscribe to either of them. There is
a difference here. Here is right wing Pastor Greg
Locke declaring that Joe Biden is an impostor,
a false prophet, an illegitimate president whose
presidency is not only false, it's also demonic.
My favorite moment is when people start to hold
their hands up in the air as Greg Locke talks
the right one place and the whole Bible that
God ever even remotely encourages me to accept
something that we know is demonic and false.
Joe Biden is not the president
of the United States of America,
as far as Greg Laucke is concerned, he's a
liar, he's an impostor. He's a false prophet.
He's an illegitimate president that did not
win, and I don't care if you send him my name,
my phone number and my mug shot that comes across
his desk, I scared his executive orders. I bow
before Jesus Christ, the king of Kings and the
Lord of Lords. I don't care what the news says.
I don't care what the FBI says. I don't care
what FOX and CNN or Newsmax do. I'm telling you,
God is bad to turn this whole thing all around.
If you believe that, give him a shot up this
morning, give him a shout of praise and
maybe drop a twenty dollar bill in the hat,
please. Right. That is either a straight
up grift or a mentally ill person, period.
After the inauguration, religious right activist
Elizabeth and Lo insists Trump will return
to office and she declares that she will not
recognize someone who was illegally elected as
president. Notice in this. If you're watching,
I guess it's her husband sitting next to her.
He just smiles as she says this stuff, as if she's
making a lot of sense and as if he's really proud.
I do believe that President Trump will be back in
that position of authority, even though there was
an inauguration yesterday. I do not and will
not recognize someone who has illegally been
elected as my president.
I just can't do that. And,
you know, I'll cut to the chase. People will ask.
Some have already asked us, well, at what point
would you kind of transition into letting
go of contending for your president Trump
being our next president for four years, not
in twenty, twenty four, but like coming now.
And I for me, I don't know the answer to that
question. I just know when when I'll know it.
And it's not now I'm not even close to being ready
to relinquish my faith and what God I shared my
heart of and what I'm hearing reflected in the
prophetic voices that I've been listening to.
It's funny. Are these people religious experts
or election experts? It's hard to tell from the
things that they're saying and notice that the
truth is in there, she says. I'm not ready to
admit Trump lost everything else, couching it
as for as faith, as prophecy, the truth about
Trump's return. It's window dressing to what she
actually admits, which is I'm just not ready to
accept that Donald Trump simply lost, which is
what happened. Here's one last one. This is from
OK. So before the election, a guy named Steve
Schultz of Alija Lipscomb said if Trump doesn't
serve a second term, I will apologize. That
was his promise before the election. Before
the inauguration. Trump is out. Biden is
in. But Steve Schultz still won't apologize.
He says God still has time to kick out Joe
Biden and bring Donald Trump back from my chair.
All legal remedies have come and gone.
They're over. So then you say, well,
then how can you possibly believe that God could
do this? God never works with possibilities. He
works with impossible, I should
say. Never does. When he wants to
show up and show up, he he makes sure every single
possibility is exhausted so that man can ever say,
see, I knew we held on long enough the Supreme
Court would do this or something like that. So so
we're giving you these prophetic proclamations and
decrees and just the prophetic where the Lord, not
based on what we see could happen, but based on
who we serve. That tells us what he's going to do.
So there it is. Depending on who
they serve, if they serve God or not,
who knows? Then God might somehow still
be able to make his prophecy correct.
I just don't understand how it's going to happen
at this point. But he's refusing to apologize
and definitely keep sending money. That's the the
one thing that binds all of these folks together
is the gravy train must not stop.
You've got to keep sending the money in.
Incredible. And people get scammed
by this. People send money to these
grifters or delusional people or some
combination of the two really horrible stuff.